hey-ey drove here with collider and I am
here with the good folks behind greener
grass I'm so happy you guys got to come
in thank you so much
so before I get started I have to give a
huge thank you to Kia can you tell your
ID specifically for being a awesome
sponsor because right it's not lighting
up right there was a lot of jokes also
with people thinking they were IKEA
there was a lot of just to be clear yeah
right no but I really mean thank you
because it's really expensive to cover
here and we get to promote your movie
you know what I mean so I first have to
start with the most important question
have you slept no I haven't I came I
came here right from Jeson oh what's
this SNL it's a show I do did you sleep
at all
I slept about 6 hours yeah before we get
started going any further most people
watching this will not have seen the
film yet and there's like not a trailer
out yet and so talk a little bit about
what the film is about
and I'll just tee it up by saying it's
based on a short film also called
greener grass it's it's basically what
we like to call the horse in the skins
of a comedy satirizing the world of
suburbia I feel like if you're like in
junior high or high school and you live
in the suburbs and you're like this
place crazy it's weird and I hate it
then you'll love this maybe
because it will you bet yes this is so
[ __ ] insane and Don and I when we
were in the Edit of the movie always
make decisions based on whether or not
French teenagers will like it and that
is because we premiered the short film
at Clermont Ferrand in France and we got
Mirage on the street by a huge group of
French teenagers who loved the short and
then got less interested in us when we
didn't have our braces anymore but we
always really let's make this decision
for the French team I don't want to say
anything but in the film my character
because she had this beautiful pair of
underwear and that just had a few tiny
holes and she didn't want to throw them
out because they're so pretty she just
uses the next car and everyone admires
them of course yes my character less
successfully has a kind of granny panty
underwear scar yes I talked a little
about the braces though because everyone
wears braces every adult has braces
right so where did that first idea come
from you know what I mean like the
genesis of it though well it's it's so
fitting that people always ask this
question we actually think it's pretty
obvious we wanted to look younger
there's so much like you guys were
talking about people who see this and
they put so much meaning on things that
you didn't intend for there to be
meaning but like if like there's so much
with braces you're like literally just
trying to look like everybody else like
trying to conform to the same smile that
everybody else has and so much of that
is suburbia is trying to like like oh
she's wearing underwear around her neck
I have to do it now too
they have this house like they have a
pool we got to get a pool they have this
thing that you know like keeping up with
each other
competing and that sort of thing I feel
like that's kind of what it yeah all the
choices are coming externally like
people are making what they want they
just see what other people have and they
want yeah I think that that you're
absolutely dealing with something that I
think a lot of people I mean you look
across social media and it's it's it's
very unhealthy I am from the suburbs I
am NOT from social media but you know I
mean listen if you grew up in suburbia
and went to high school you in America
you understand you know looking at
everybody else and what they have and
what you covet and if you don't have it
you got to get it yeah being competitive
with their kids being like this kids
doing this thing don't you want to do
that yeah like don't you want to achieve
what they're getting into this school
like you know getting you tutors so you
can mean that whole thing yeah I'm
curious though what does it like on set
when you have a lot of people that can
laugh and make all jokes what is it like
keeping it all together and the
challenge also when you take that to the
edit when you have so many different
great alts that is a true challenge way
yes we had especially with these two but
so many of the characters in this movie
are incredible improvisers and just
hilarious comedians and we did spend
long hours an edit like trying to not
kill every improv darling but that being
said there I would say there wasn't a
ton of improv once we were actually on
set and but such wonderful gems here and
there we were said before but the script
has so much in it that you want to make
sure that you capture what's written you
don't want to like so we like Reddit and
we're like we want to say that I suppose
like oh I can make this better
it's like they they know this world so
well that like if there was an
improvement it was like a slight thing
or like you know maybe a little add-on
here or there but like it was pretty
much sticking to what they wrote I feel
like both Beck and Mary actually have
all these amazing little like size and
like grunts and things like in addition
to other like improv
these incredible little like sounds and
like little face things that they do
that I feel like those we like relish
yeah actually our incredible sound mixer
GERD Whitley was telling us you know I
have to tell you something about the
mechs so normally I really go through
and I clean up mouth sounds but with
your movie I really left them always and
and yeah I would just echo what Beck was
saying that the script was so concise
and and there was so much to be acted in
silences and in the pauses where the the
improv like those little moments of
reactions or grunts or something yeah I
feel like that's where the improv was
because you you didn't want to fill
those silences you want those to really
be there because that's so much a part
of the the discomfort of the movie yeah
you guys I just want to say that a $5 or
$10 compliment I'm keeping track it was
15 yeah you guys are part of the
midnight selection at Sundance and I
love the midnight selection we do - oh
we're so happy right I was gonna say so
when did you find out you got in and was
when you were onset making it were you
what was thinking you know we could
dance with this we feel very grateful to
be here
and we we were completely blown away
when we got a call from deal SIA that we
were in the festival but what was funny
is Don and I were actually directing
something that was shooting on location
north of LA and we were staying in a
Holiday Inn Express which is the exact
hotel chain that we all stay there shot
greener grass outside of Atlanta had a
great time loved it there yeah so it was
this weird
of us being in a room at the Holiday Inn
Express finding out we got into Sundance
in the same like world that we made the
movie it was so strange I've been I want
before I run out of time with you guys I
definitely we've been playing get to
know your Sundance attendee with a lot
of people coming through I promise these
are harmless questions I think for you
to what TV show would you love to guest
write and direct and then for the two of
you I know you guys act but I'm going to
do the get the writing directing part
and for you guys what TV show would you
love to guest star on oh my gosh oh my
god let you guys do the writing director
you know yeah I feel like I have mine
yeah true detective I would so love to
be on that and I think it can happen I
think I really fit I don't know if
anyone's seen Lindsay Lohan's beach
house
I would love to step in and direct that
there is not enough Lindsay on that show
and I think I could fix that and this is
just what I'd like to act in now what
like Oh tonight I think succession we
can make you barely even have to ask
like it's like um if people like move
out of the suburbs or whatever they like
go to the succession world like the Wall
Street like business like that so many
people when I ask this question say
succession so that I don't even really
watch the show that much I just like the
world right a lot of people are into it
so um do you guys have a favorite sci-fi
or fantasy film
I loved the new Blade Runner that's the
first thing that came to me it is
fantastic - a real recent topical
reference may be the neverending story a
real recent one oh my gosh I love
fantasy so much I loved all the Lord of
the Rings but I recently revisited ex
machina and I loved that movie so that
that kind of sticks out to me is mine
sci-fi The Matrix sure that's alright it
is I mean it's a classic it was my
favorite in high school I don't I don't
know if I've thought about that in a
while I'm sure I have another one that's
more recent I answered earlier the Lord
of the Rings extended editions I love
the trilogy but listen I could also say
2001 the list is deep for me deep you
know what I mean do you guys have a
favorite superhero movie since the
superhero genre is so popular The Dark
Knight sure it's probably my favorite
that one works for a lot of people
Batman
oh that Michael Keaton yeah that I love
that you guys okay I'll go because I
know what I'm gonna say yeah because I
know what I'm gonna say
I actually well I really like Deadpool
I love Deadpool I really thought that
was super fun this is just the wrong
question for me I am so not up on
superhero movies yeah I truly can't
think of one totally fine that is Wonder
Woman to see what I did enjoy Wonder
Woman Wonder was yeah
oh so you're basically lying to me yeah
I know one movie I have no idea how this
holds up among superhero movies but when
I saw this movie in the theater at a
very young age I felt lots of things and
enjoyed it very much and that is Spider
Man with Tobey Maguire I have not seen
it since
but maybe the last superhero movie I saw
but yeah you know something it worked
for you though I like black panther a
lot Iron Man was amazing movies all
movies
what film scared you as a kid it so
scared yep
after seeing that I had to shower with a
washcloth over the drain watcher in the
woods it's about like a woman who lives
in a house and it's haunted and someone
spells narak which is Karen backwards in
a window and it's only if you're willing
to be frightened yes mine was it as well
and that really messed me up yeah my
children of the corn saw that I like my
friend's house they were allowed to
watch those movies and I was not and I
was not ready for it
there's also that movie was the guy like
on a train was like a wig I don't forget
I said anything
very hairy guy on the train he's got
like hair he's gonna train sound like
TNT like flipping through channels again
peri guy on the train what movie I think
it was like they were trying to like
jump on the success of like Halloween is
there anything that you guys collect
collect yeah I'm throwing some
curveballs but it's not it's a little
weird usually collects like I'm into
shoes I like screen prints you know
oops I don't want them but I don't know
what to do throw them away
sans with them what are you talking
about pull out some your hair and burn
em stars I have your Halloween costume
for next year and it involves your teeth
sneakers what I have to do a follow-up
mine's gonna be embarrassing because
okay okay but no I was just gonna say is
it something where you have an unhealthy
collection um for a while when I was
like figuring out what I liked I would
just buy sneakers and now it's loaned
out a lot okay I mean I do you own you
own over 50 pairs I don't think so right
around here right around 40 oh yeah I'm
trying to keep because I don't have
anywhere to put 60 or 80 out
avvocato oh boy I I mean really the
first thing that came to my mind was I
collect compliments I collect large
versions of little things oh so like you
know five foot tall spoon and 12 foot
long drinking straw which that's not
okay anymore straws are out and then
like pencils pens I just I find them
funny and I don't know why they just
bring me delight sure there's nothing
wrong with making yourself happy
nothing do you guys remember your first
movie or TV show crush oh Christian Bale
in Newsies hard oh my god yeah
I relate to the like how fast that
answer was some people have to think
she's like nope I got it
was and this is a kind of upsetting mine
was Tommy Lee Jones and Coal Miner's
Daughter again not the usual answer to
this day though Tommy Lee Jones call me
I love you my girl and then Jennifer
Love Hewitt and I know what you did last
summer I had such a crush on Bart
Simpson to my core
is there a TV show you've watched all
the way through more than once yeah I
had watched Friday Night Lights yes I've
seen that through maybe three times Sex
in the City the so many times yeah
visited Breaking Bad but I haven't
watched it all the way through twice
it's funny you mentioned that because we
have three this or that's and this or
that means which one would you prefer a
Star Wars or Star Trek Star Wars Star
Wars Star Wars okay
Game of Thrones are Breaking Bad game is
making bed Game of Thrones I have never
seen either this is the get to know your
Sunday it's a 10-day Han Solo or Indiana
Jones Indiana in my last question for
you guys do you remember what it was
when you're growing up that's like you
saw a performance or a movie or TV show
and said hey like oh my god I want to do
that yes of course
Dorothy Wizard of Oz yeah okay for me it
was cats I remember I went and saw it
was my first time seen a show and we
were in visiting family outside DC and I
remember seeing it and during the
intermission I was like what they do
during it
they scan the audience to see if there
are any kids out there who want to be in
the show so I'm gonna sit there and I'm
gonna look like I want to be the show
that's how I thought theatre worked and
that's when I knew I had to be a part of
it
mine was The Parent Trap that movie
Hayley Mills yes Hayley Mills just
obsessed with it it's like I just wanted
a twin and then I also was like that
would be a cool thing to do movie like
that I remember a lot of my influences
like growing up me like I want but like
I don't remember having that moment of
like I want to do that until like I saw
I mean the only one that I can remember
is seeing long day's journey and tonight
I'm Broadway with Philip Seymour Hoffman
engine and Vanessa Redgrave and Brian
Dennehy and I was just like completely
um I just I'll stop there and just say
again a huge thank you to Kia for you
tell your ID for being an awesome
sponsor and sincerely thank you so much
for coming in I hope everyone gets to
see the film and thank you so much for
coming in the studio I wish you nothing
but the best
[Music]
you